good morning John it's Friday I am
currently at the YouTube Creator Summit
look at this what is a little event that
YouTube has been throwing for creators
for a while but not recently so this is
the first one in a long time and I'm
really excited to be here seeing Old
Friends making new friends thinking
about what it all means I was just
talking to a guy who was like can you
believe the power that is inside of this
room the cultural creation that occurs
at the hands of these people now
obviously YouTube is a lot bigger than
the people who are in that room but it
is interesting and they're a lot of
interesting and I think important
conversations one of the things that
folks were trying to get to the bottom
of a lot is that YouTube is kind of
undergoing one of the biggest shifts in
how content on the platform Works in a
very long time and that is specifically
uh that there are these things called
shorts which are what YouTube calls tick
tocks except that's actually it's
probably best not to call them that
because ultimately YouTube is culturally
very different from Tick Tock obviously
YouTube wanted to clone the
effectiveness of that content tool but
that doesn't mean that it's going to be
the same thing there are lots of
different things and they are extremely
subtle that go into what content gets
made and how the platform feels like
what its Vibe is this by the way is the
thing that says I don't have covid so
that's how you get one of those and
that's an example of how important and
subtle this is I think that we
misunderstand what is the difference
between a YouTube video and a YouTube
short or a tick tock or an Instagram
meal or whatever and and I think it's
important for everyone on Earth to
understand this and the people who most
think about it oftentimes don't so
you're gonna now get ahead of those
people it's not about this it's not
about it being vertical it's not about
it being short the biggest difference
between a YouTube short and a YouTube
video is that one you decide whether to
watch it and the other you decide
whether to keep watching it does that
make sense to you because the difference
is massive when I'm trying to decide
whether to watch a YouTube video I'm
presented with many YouTube videos and
they have titles and they have
thumbnails and they have faces of people
I may or may not recognize many of those
people I care about I know their stories
I've been involved with their stories
for many years even if I've never met
them with a tick tock or a real or a
short I'm not deciding what video to
watch I am deciding which video I keep
watching I think there are a lot of
things that people would watch that they
kind of don't think they would I think
that some of that content is probably
not that great fail videos football
highlights it's fine and I think there
are a lot of videos that I click on that
maybe wouldn't be the thing that I would
most stick around to watch in a feed of
otherwise very engaging content but when
you're not deciding whether to watch
you're deciding whether to keep watching
I think you're a lot more open to new
creators so both of these things are
good don't get me wrong they can both do
bad things and they could both function
in a bad way if we use them poorly but I
am glad to have both of them at first
everyone isn't really sure if that was
the case but I think it's really
important that we have systems that
allow for the discovery of new talented
interesting Innovative creators I feel
like Tick Tock and Tick Tock like things
are really great for Discovery and for
people to sort of build early in their
career it's like a greenhouse there's a
lot of energy packed into a really small
space and it allows for a lot of
diversity and a lot of thriving but only
certain kinds of things can grow forever
in a greenhouse most things have to move
out of the greenhouse in order to keep
growing and thriving it's really deeply
different and I think that the only
actual difference is not the format it's
not the length it's whether you choose
to watch it or whether you choose to
keep watching it it's really amazing to
me how massive the impacts on our
culture such subtle changes in these
content platforms can have and so many
of those massively important differences
are really subtle and terribly difficult
to notice I think that it is valuable to
notice them and that's what I've been
thinking about here at the YouTube
Creator Summit John I will see you on
Monday because next week
begins